okay now i would be remiss today if i
did not discuss
one of the great issues of our time and
that is
that the actress ellen page who is was
and shall remain a woman
is now a man so let me read you the
headline from cnn which conveys
zero information and we have now been
forced as a society
to simply say nonsense to simply just
say things that are nonsense that don't
make any sort of logical sense
that don't actually translate from
english
to reason okay so here is the headline
and you tell me if you know what
what the hell this means okay ready
elliot page junostar
shares transgender identity do you have
any idea what that means
like seriously do you have an idiot that
means when i first saw the headline
elliott page i thought whoa ellen has a
brother no it turns out that ellen page
is now identifying as elliott page
and the media instead of saying here's a
headline with content ellen page
announces she identifies as man wishes
to be called
elliott page right now i would have the
whole story but elliott paige junostar
conveys nothing because ellen page was
the star of juno
so i'm like wait was her brother in that
movie like i don't even know what you're
talking about right now
because the media have created this
bizarre
standard whereby if a person declares
themselves a member of the opposite
gender the entire world
especially in the media must immediately
flip on a dime stop calling them by the
name everybody knew them as
and stop calling them by their
biological sex you end up with complete
nonsense
just complete bl coming out of the
mouths of the media
now listen ellen page can identify
however she wants i don't care
really it makes no difference to me she
is an adult human she can do whatever
she wants it is a free country
however it being a free country i am
also free to point out that ellen page
is was and shall remain a woman
because ellen page is in fact a woman
now i'm happy to call ellen page elliott
if she wants to be called elliott
because people change their names all
the time and you can in fact change your
name by declaration
you cannot however change your sex by
declaration or your gender by
declaration that is not how this works
there is no other area of life
in which people simply declare
themselves to be a thing and everybody
goes oh okay
right an objectively verifiable thing
right there you can declare
your sexual orientation where you can
declare a thing that you like you can
declare that you're a fan of this
particular band you can declare that you
have a sexual attraction to x y or z
right that's all subjective
and all we have to go on is your
behavior which is objective and your
subjective self-assessment
however when you're declaring something
as core as your sex
there's no objectifiable no objective
measure whatsoever
whereby ellen page is a man none right
she is a woman
and yet we are immediately told by the
media that to even address
ellen page or elliot page as a she is
discriminatory
it's very bad and very discriminatory
and so you end up with complete
inanities and insanities
okay so ellen page declared that
she is now a man okay but she also
declared that she is a queer man
now this is confusing because if she
were a queer man this would mean that
she is attracted to men
which would technically mean that she's
a straight woman right
because if she is an actual woman
attracted to men this would make her a
straight woman but we know she's not
that
because she was a lesbian right so she
is married to a woman
as far as i'm aware and that means that
she is a lesbian but now she is
a man and according to her this means
that she is a white
straight male so how she queer she's a
white straight male
so here is how wikipedia tries to sum
this up you ready for this
according to wikipedia in
in january 2018 paige publicly announced
his marriage to dancer and choreographer
emma portner so this means
that ellen page is a gay man married to
a woman according to wikipedia
which makes no sense at all like
in any way shape or form and you're
expected to simply mirror this
not only that the left has particular
standards with regard to who gets to
play parts and movies so for example
ellen page now now elliott page right
i'm saying ellen page not because i wish
to offend elliot page
but because until five seconds ago
nobody had ever heard of elliott page
nobody knows who the hell i'm talking
about so i'm going to use the name that
people know her as
and then over time if you want to call
it la page that's fine but for like
today i feel like it's fair
to mention that ellen page and elliott
page are the same person so that if
somebody tunes in and hears elliot page
they don't think ellen has a brother
okay
so here's the headline from tv insider
elliot page reportedly cont to continue
in same role on umbrella academy
now umbrella academy on netflix uh it
started off that the series itself
is based on a comic book in the comic
book ellen page
who again is a woman and is in the
series a cisgender woman
right like a woman who is a woman is a
uh
is a straight woman in the first season
in the second season ellen page becomes
a lesbian because ellen page
is a lesbian in real life i guess um i
mean i assume that's that's what the
plan
was there and that it has something to
do with how ellen page wanted to act
because
my understanding is that's not something
directly from the comic book series if
it is
forgive me that's fine who cares okay
but here's the part that's hilarious
so according to variety they say there
are no plans to change
the character ellen page plays her
gender
on the umbrella academy so the series is
publicly showing their support
and they say they are proud of their
superhero
we love you elliot but elliott will be
playing a woman
now i've been firmly informed that this
is discrimination and cultural
appropriation
when scarlett johansson a straight woman
was slated to play a transgender man
in a movie this was considered very very
bad form
in fact only trans people could play
trans characters so i have a question
if elliot page is in fact a man the way
that the media have declared that she is
a man
then why is she allowed to play a
cisgender woman is that not cultural
appropriation
if a normal non-trans man decided to
play a woman today
everybody would suggest that this was a
violation of long-standing norms it was
cultural appropriation
but if a woman declares herself a man
then you have to make a choice either
she is a man in which case she can't
play a woman anymore or she is not a man
in which case she's not a man
but because our culture is unbelievably
stupid it is both right that is the way
that this works
so good news elliot page can still play
women
and also can play transgender men
presumably can also play
men men which is really exciting one
further note on all of this
if you feel like this is crazy and that
this is being crammed down on you that
is because it is
that is because this is not a fringe
phenomenon anymore
right this is something the democratic
party fully embraces and pushes
yesterday chuck schumer the senate
minority leader
he said that he is fully with joe biden
on mandating
from the federal government that
transgender people be allowed to use the
bathroom of their choice
now it seems to me that if my wife is
uncomfortable
with a male walking into a bathroom or a
locker room
where she is undressing at the gym that
that is perfectly within her purview
that seems like not inappropriate at all
to me but
the federal government has now decided
under democratic auspices that men and
women
are exactly the same that gender is
completely fluid
none of this makes any internal sense by
the way if men and women are completely
same
the same there's no reason for yourself
for you to declare yourself a man that
man equals woman means woman equals
woman
right i mean it's just the basic
transitive property in any case here is
chuck schumer
you know fully green lighting the
democratic agenda which is fully in line
with all this this
silliness and anti-logic nonsense and
again ellen page or elliot page is
allowed to do whatever she wants to do
today but she does not get to dictate
what the rest of us
say about things as basic as biological
sex and capital t
truth okay but here is here's the
democratic party pushing this stuff
joe biden said that on his first day of
office he will give
transgender students access to sports
bathrooms and locker rooms in accordance
with their gender identity in all
federally funded schools
do you think he has the ability to do
this and do you agree with this decision
i agree with the decision and i know
he'll check things out thoroughly
legally
okay i'm sure that this will all work
out just fantastically well
i'm sure and don't feel bullied don't
feel as though you are being forced
to change long-standing and for all of
human history held opinions
about the non-malleability of sex uh it
is all because you're discriminatory in
your mind
don't worry about the fact that this is
all illogical it makes no sense the
media have told you that a thing is so
and therefore it is so
and therefore and also if you if you
mention it it's because you are
it's because you're obsessed with these
issues this is one of my favorites is
that
you say something is radical as men and
women are exactly the same in a man can
become a woman and then i say no
they're like why are you even paying
attention to this why are you even
making an issue out of this
i'm not you guys are i'm sorry but you
purveyors of of
new truths that have nothing to do with
science logic
reason the answer is no the answer is no
i do not go along
with your with your mandatory take on
the world and i don't think americans
should either
that's not an excuse for being nasty to
people it's not an excuse for
discrimination
it is a recommendation that we all speak
real truths when they are available
and it happens to be a real truth that
elliot page is was and will remain a
woman
even if elliot page believes that she is
a man and you're under no obligation
moral or otherwise to suggest that men
can become women or to teach that to
your children which is really what the
left wants out of this whole deal
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity hit the like button